and finally new rules someone needs to
explain to me how there have been over
1200 books written about the Trump
presidency books that were mostly
competing to reveal every detail of his
life and not one of them tells me the
one thing I'm most curious about
who is Donald Trump [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] somebody
all right
and it's not Melania and it's not nobody
that went away after he became the most
powerful man in the world how is it
possible I don't have the answer to this
question
who is blowing Donald Trump
how could it be that if you read every
page of fire and fury confidence Man
team of vipers a very stable genius
betrayal disloyal Revenge unhinged rage
fear Peril Blitz full disclosure the
divider and the room where it happened
you'd still have no idea what happened
in the room
[Laughter]
we know everything else about the guy
down to the most minute detail because
everyone around him has the Loyalty of a
pet scorpion
[Applause]
all white houses are a bit of a sieve
but the Trump White House leaked more
than Nick Cannon's condoms
[Applause]
we we know he cuts his own hair with
giant scissors
we know he listens to show tunes to calm
down we know he gets two scoops of ice
cream and everybody else gets one
laughs
we know we tweeted on the toilet and
throws documents down the toilet here
we know he cheats of golf was once
caught eating paper and doesn't like
dogs is a germaphobe uses a tanning bed
once cashed a check for 13 cents
has his pants steamed while wearing them
sleeps four hours a night and hesitated
to give Don Jr his name because what if
he's a loser
we
we even know that his penis is shaped
like a mushroom
how is it possible we don't know who is
servicing it
and don't tell me it's nobody he's on
tape bragging that when you're a star
you can do anything you want okay that
guy didn't just go away
alpha dogs never die never
Quinn
had a baby out of wedlock at 78.
[Laughter]
his wife was very mad at him and then he
did it again at 81.
[Applause]
lecherous old prime minister Silvio
Berlusconi was having bunga bunga
parties in his 70s
do you think Donald Trump just one day
said yes sex was fun but I think I'll
switch to building ships in a bottle
[Laughter]
and again we know it's not Melania
please please it's just not she won't
even give him hand
no no
she hates him and he's made it plain
he's not into women her age
for him she's a milled a mom I'd like to
divorce
do they even live together is she alive
just to live completely as a single man
still Alpha still crazy and I bet still
horny it doesn't add up someone or some
team of people
Lindsey Graham could be involved
someone is blowing Donald Trump and it's
a scandal we don't know what the Scandal
is we certainly know all about his past
sex life the cheating the groping the
walking into the dressing room at beauty
pageants hot for daughter
foreign
to be dating them in 10 years
the parties with Epstein the grabbing
[ __ ] the porn star mistress
everything and then the historical
record goes blank
[Laughter]
why can't we unearth his bone
[Applause]
not even anything from the last two
years when he's at Mar-A-Lago he lives
at a country club with hundreds of
people coming and going he wouldn't even
have to fake how the groupies got in
and they must get in he's a man who
lives to be adored
and Florida is full of thousands of
unhinged maggot [ __ ]
who see him as sent by God to save
America and it's well-known Evangelical
chicks are the freakiest
get laid there is no way this is not
happening who is blowing Donald Trump
have to know this I have a right to know
this it's not like these are the days of
JFK when the media covered up in
Discretions for the sake of the country
oh right the media has too much class to
blab
this would get the most clicks ever
Twitter would be so lit up Elon would
have to hire back all the employees
I mean
I don't count on the news media for much
anymore but I do expect them to tell me
who's [ __ ] who
unless
no it couldn't be I well unless the
answer Donald is you just can't
come on
well I
I remember
I remember you once guaranteed that
there was no problem
I guarantee you there's no problem I
guarantee
well maybe there is
maybe there is a problem in which case I
feel for you no I'm just saying I'm not
trying to bait you into a response to
prove your dick worked
maybe it does it's possible
theoretically but
but really there's no other explanation
how a cult leader with hundreds of
willing groupies who's not restrained by
his wife by his options or by morals
could not be having sex with anyone I
wouldn't be surprised if you nicknamed
your penis Mike Pence
because it's not hung like it should be
anyway Donald I know you're thinking
about running again so I just want to
say good luck with the campaign and now
that your own party thinks of you as a
loser remember no one wants a limp dick
in the White House